how is uh you you kind of are also
becoming as well known as an actor as
you are an artist because there's some
people who discovered who you are
through acting Who acting facts
um obviously you're a [__] rapper
you're a rappers rapper but like uh how
a lot of [__] are you diving in on the
acting all the way all the way that's
the [__] that had an old white ladies in
the in the in the in the airport
like [__] that I didn't get from rap you
know with rap I already certain [__]
with rap like I know if I walk in this
Popeyes you know someone's gonna know it
is predominantly black or Spanish like
somebody gonna spot me like but when I
go through the airport and there's like
an older white lady or the younger Asian
kid or you know I mean like it just be
so many different
races that you know I mean that that
that tapped into me acting and I feel
like it just kind of like
brought in my rap [__] even more like it
kind of just built this [__] like and
put it out more are you like going well
[__] are you on strike right now strike
one for acting are you on strike I ain't
on no strike are you a part of sag after
I'm more sag but I ain't yeah you're on
strike I didn't even know it you're
stuck right now hey Dave you're on
strike man I'm hot I'm ready to act what
you talking about no no you're not don't
say that Dave you cannot cross pick you
can't cross the picket line
you signed a waiver already
it's on me too that's crazy that means
you're on strike you know they hold down
your dental you know all that good [__]
they take care of the benefits that's
why you got to stand with sag that's the
union you heard
so I must be on strike you're on strike
you must be on strike you'll go go tune
in the Wu-Tang man it's three seasons of
that [__] and I did Beats big shout out
to Chris Robinson Anthony Anderson
uh they put me in my first film that was
a Netflix movie right yeah that was the
first film I did Big shout out to
Gabrielle Union she put me on um uh the
Mary Jane on BT that was early are you
trying everybody that that that that
helped me get into that big big shout
out to them
all the time I do matter AJ always
sending me auditions and [__] like that
but I was saying before I was telling
the homie like
I'm more into the like you know
directors know who they want in the
movie you can audition all year for the
most part yeah I mean but for the most
part you gotta like wow somebody you
gotta change their mind they know who
they want right you know what I'm saying
so I'm more into that like you know what
I mean I got a lot of [__] going on I'm
a fall of a rapper I own a store there's
a lot I got going on so I'm not against
the auditions East Coast I got the pain
you know we got pain out here in these
streets but I got a lot going on so I'm
more into the like not East I see you
for this role right then I'll do the
audition but I know you already got me
in mind for that you know what I'm
saying instead of me just like yo let's
try to go get that like right right uh I
ain't doing that is there fake eastco in
New York they bootlegging everything Kev
yeah well I asked because I was in
Detroit
liquor store in Detroit we're selling uh
bootleg empty bags of this you could buy
to stuff your weed in and like it's you
know that's but I'm gonna be real with
you I seen uh I watched I was why I was
on YouTube I seen Tupac get mad about
bootlegging
uh who else I see Capo big bro Jim I see
I've seen a few people that that don't
like that right a little while liking
this [__] or what you doing
bootleg my [__] cause that tell me is
hot and it's like if it ain't cracking
it ain't gonna bootlegg it like if it
ain't like like I feel like bootlegging
will always be the streets that's crazy
that's your name like that's what I used
to do what made you name yourself
because I used to be [__] you got
busy with on a boole pirating music and
purses and shoes and jerseys and you was
thinking about a dog I mean I was like
16 trying to support it you think about
a dollar bro I could never knock nobody
hustle I was bootlegging a lot of [__]
though you know what I mean we had I'm a
person that don't I'm not mad at the
boot like I was I was The Bootlegger in
Arizona for like two years two years you
had everything oh everything if you need
it come see you you had it oh I shout
out to I always tell us the game but I
would say on the documentary [__] for
like two months before it came out I
made so much money in high school before
it dropped oh yeah I was [__] at the
CD burner booming
you remember we're the same age ish uh
the picture tees 100 so I used to make
them [__] at the swap meet so you
could just print whatever one whatever
you wanted to have like the [__]
movie which you were selling them for
twenty dollars probably 25 25. but yeah
and then I had the purses I had the Bro
remember when yt's was jumping at home
you can get three White T's for ten
dollars
then you'd be like you'd have like a 50
Cent mug shot too and you could get them
and then you'd have a Scarface tea and
then you'd have a mixtape if you want a
mixtape and if you wanted a fake pair of
Tiffany dunks I could get you right
Canal Street man they had I was Canal
Street in Arizona I was dealing directly
with with the lady in China yeah that's
good now they had the Gucci Knights
nah [__] that it's Time Square now too
the Africans in Times Square booming
bro I bought a fake Louis belt like six
months ago in New York and it's it's
holding up nicely and I I have real
Louis belts but I got a fake one but you
you cab so nobody gonna think that's
fair also if they that's what people
don't know they found out my name's
bootleg Kev suck my dick this is what I
learned with once you have a name or you
got then they feel like you gotta you
got money they could they could Google
you Wikipedia whatever
you can wear face [__] I just seen
Kendrick he just went and bought them
fake Jordans you saw that yes but that's
Kendrick Lamar so what are you gonna say
and who's gonna say anything today
put on whatever you want you see I pull
up white tea That's What uh Cinco said
he said uh he never bought any real
jewelry because he's like yeah the
[__] that dress up all the time they
trying too hard oh yeah when the
designer's wearing them they trying to
they trying they trying to keep the
rapper cost too much they're trying to
keep an image or the human costume Jesus
I know so many people in my life now
that [__] got money during the
pandemic
and they the designer is wearing you bro
you're not wearing the designer it's
wearing you
a lot of designers and if I go in them
stores and I see [__] I like I'll buy it
for sure but I'm saying like my man [__]
on before I'm gonna go some of these
guys you know what I mean yeah always
been like that like my man got something
I don't care if it's a belt
I don't care if it's a it's a I don't
give a [__] what it is a fitted socks
shorts tees sweatsuit I'm gonna put my
man [__] on somebody from the hush you
know before